this very night you're going to meet the
first eight single men oh good oh gosh
take it a little bit by bit I have seen
them and um
there's heat coming off he's five years
so tonight ladies is a masquerade ball
each of you and all of the men will be
wearing masks
it will avoid you guys judging a book by
its cover personality
that's the way I prefer anyway you want
them to get past the fame and the looks
and get to know the real you
okay so what time the party starts
[Music]
hold up wait a minute I ain't finished
okay everybody let's mingle ladies
so your name is Jr
and yours
I'll tell you later you'll tell me later
well I like that I only dated one person
who was not in the
end don't want to date
I like executives
and men that are stupid
would you like to accompany me uh for
sure I love this outfit geez
do you have children three freeloaders
I think I have four why swimming boys 17
16. I think my youngest is almost 13. so
you don't want to kids I know I look
like a 20 year old man
I'm a socializer so I immediately just
started asking questions you from here
what do you do do you have children how
old are y'all do you want to get married
I feel like you only live once you
better say something what they say a
closed mouth don't get fat
where are you from
um I am from New York I'm from the Bronx
oh wow it's a nice dress thank you it's
texture it says a lot about your
personality really what does it say yeah
you don't crush velvet
you guys have kids or I have an
eight-year-old son oh you do I have an
eight-year-old son too so what are the
ages I'm 44. 37 37 I'm 46. 46. nice yeah
I remember that's 29. oh okay yeah I'm
sorry maybe you could actually do
something to him and then we'll kind of
make us a little bit simpler
seen some of these men wear masks on I'm
hoping not to see any of my exes It's a
Small World sometimes you just never
know six four oh you got a good night
what's the last new thing you tried I'm
a very sexual person but I've never been
handcuffed so um but I tried it and I
thought that was so cool even like I
started panicking
okay
I'm from New Orleans originally oh
you're from New Orleans yes ma'am you
have children I do I'm 45. divorce
father five why oh yeah beautiful all
the kids all from your wife no so how
many baby mamas I have four
four five four
uh that's a red flag for me isn't it
beautiful to see their individual
personality and chances are you have
baby mama drama and I don't want to deal
with that either I look forward to
talking to you more sounds good so Jr
there's a no for me
thank you